Le programme des fusées sondes est suspendu
jusqu'à l'organisation d'un événement majeur :
L'année géophysique internationale.
Récemment, l'idée d'une année internationale
géophysique a été lancée par plus de 60 nations.
Efforts scientifiques à l'échelon mondial,
en vue de faire progresser notre découverte
du monde planétaire et de l'infini.
Ces hommes de science et leurs gouvernements
respectifs décidèrent de se livrer,
pendant la durée
de l'année géophysique internationale,
à de nouvelles recherches scientifiques
pour le bénéfice de la communauté mondiale.
Ça, c'est un contexte
qui a joué un rôle important.
Avec comme objectif de faire
une étude globale de la Terre,
et, nouveauté,
de faire une étude à la verticale.
Donc d'explorer toute la haute atmosphère,
la banlieue terrestre, c'était un grand projet.
Et c'est à l'occasion de cet événement
scientifique mondial,
que la course à l'espace
a réellement commencé.
À la surprise générale,
les Soviétiques devancent les Américains.
Le 4 octobre 1957, le célèbre "bip bip"
du satellite Spoutnik résonne dans le monde.
La France, avec un peu de retard,
va elle aussi, participer
à cette année géophysique.
Elle souhaite accéder à la haute atmosphère
pour réaliser ses propres expériences.
Le programme Véronique est ressuscité,
avec dès le début la contestation
de la classe scientifique,
qui craint que le budget engagé
pour le développement des fusées,
empiète fortement sur celui des expériences.
Une véronique améliorée et mise au point,
plus fiable, plus puissante.
Ce sera la Véronique dite AGI,
pour Année Géophysique Internationale.
Toute une série
de ses fusées est développée,
pour être opérationnelle
dans les premiers mois de 1959.
On s'est trouvé avec un programme
français spatial qui comportait 15 Véronique,
c'est-à-dire des fusées sondes
qui devaient monter à 200 kilomètres,
en portant une centaine de kilos
qui n'avait encore jamais été tiré,
et qui pourtant ne portait rien.
On ne savait pas quoi faire.
Si la France se démène pour mettre au point
ses fusées sondes Véronique,
elle ne maîtrise pas encore à l'époque,
les instruments permettant
de réceptionner depuis le sol,
les mesures effectuées en vol
par les outils embarqués.
Ce qu'on appelle la télé mesure.
Cette lacune limite les possibilités d'expériences
scientifiques à placer dans les Véronique AGI.
Il faut alors trouver une solution
pour faire taire les contestataires.
Et c'est le jeune chercheur Jacques Blamont
qui va suggérer une idée très simple.
Il recommande d'utiliser les fusées
en s'inspirant d'expériences américaines.
Il va proposer de disperser du
sodium dans la haute atmosphère,
pour en observer et mesurer le comportement.
Une expérience originale
qui ne nécessite pas de télé mesure.
Je prétendais, et ça a effectivement
été réalisé,
qu'on pouvait mesurer
un paramètre très important,
et pourtant inconnu,
la température de l'atmosphère.
Dans la tête de la fusée, les savants
ont installé leur appareil de mesure,
et une charge de sodium qui sera éjectée
dans la haute atmosphère.
Un des arguments que j'avais donné
pour l'emploi des nuages de sodium,
c'est que ça se verrait.
Ça se voyait à 1000 kilomètres.
Les 3 1ᵉʳˢ tirs de Véronique AGI
réalisés en mars 1959,
seront consacrés à cette expérience.
Ils vont permettre à Jacques Blamont de faire
une découverte scientifique sensationnelle,
qui va ouvrir la voie des expériences scientifiques
françaises dans la haute atmosphère.
Jacques Blamont découvre une limite de
l'atmosphère qui sera appelée Turbopause.
C'est bien simple,
vous avez un nuage de sodium,
c'est-à-dire une traînée
qui suit la trajectoire de la fusée.
Ça commence à marcher quand
il n'y a plus beaucoup d'oxygène,
donc au-dessus de 100 kilomètres.
Alors cette trainée, elle se trouve
dans le milieu où il y a des vents,
les vents la pousse et donc on voit
cette trainée se déformer très fortement.
Alors de cette déformation,
on déduisait l'existence d'une série
de mouvement dans la haute atmosphère,
qui apparaissent à partir de la stratosphère
et qui sont très importants.
Vous décrivez la physique, la dynamique
de l'atmosphère de cette manière-là,
qui était inconnue.
Mais en plus, il se trouve que quand
vous voyez les photos du nuage de sodium,
vous voyez qu'au-dessus de 100 kilomètres,
le nuage est très lisse,
au-dessous de 100 kilomètres aussi bien
à la montée qu'à descente, il est globuleux.